E
THAT DECIONHIC OF DONALLE WHO
BEHIND.ICAN OFFICE HOLDASTA G C
PARKINSON'S HIDEATH WAS
SOMETHING OF A SURPRIS
THEY W VACCINATED, AGH
E FOVID AND
MAS OKAY COLINE HA
COMPROMIIMMUNE WHAT DONALD
ABOUT TG WAR VETERAN ANGENERAL
POWELL WHO MADE MISTAKES O
IRAQ AND FALLED
DESTRUCTION BED IN DEATH S
BYAKE NEWS MEDIA.
HOPE THAT HAPPS TO CLASSIC RINO
THAT. BO ATMISTAKESANYWAY, MAY
FOLLOWETO DONATE MONEY  DONALD.
HE DID JOHL AND HN
PUS
ARE  UND TS. STATEMENTS OVER AN
OVER, IT ALL COMES BACK
LFND OAIN AND IT'SLL
SH GUESS W
SHOUT  RUBTHIS POINT TO REALLYO.
K CHENEY AND A
THINK WE'RE NOT GOINBUT I
REPUBLICANS --
>> IS THOUGH?INK ANYTHING A
THIS IS SHOCKING.
>> S
WAS TLATAFF. LIFESEG HIMSEL
DONALDS THE FIRST WAIT
CH PRESIDENT.
T WANT TO ATTACKONALLYS ITOWTO
HE TALKS'L REMEMBERED ASTHE MOS
HAS D THIS CS YT.
>> AND IT'S TUALLY A PAL
GIFT FOR.
EVERY TIME HE DOES THIS,E
REMINDPE REVOLTED FROM
SUBUANE N VOTERS WHO NOW HAVE R
VERY F
EVERY TIME H THIS AND Y TIME
UNDERTONES IN SOME OF HIS
STATTS THEY GO FURTHER AND
FURTHER AY.RE DEMOCRATS ARE T H.
>> IT T.AN LIZAS , EW
S, CALLING
THIS IIN COMMENTS RE
PATHETAGAIN, THERE'S A VERCONTE
VIRGINIA R.
AND I'M SURE GLEGKIN, THBLICANOE
ADTYD.
WHAT ABO WHAT AB
>>A
ADD SAYING THAHEWOUL- HE WOULD S
NOMINEE IN 2024.
T LETS YOU KNO
YOUNGKIN STANDS TETOTRUMP AND T
INSURRECTI TN ,
WORKED I J A
NAITY AND DEFENSE
THINK TA A COLIN PS
INSPIRED GENERATIONS OSECUPOLICG
LEADERSHIP, HISINSPIRATION TO
DEFENSUNITY.
N'T HAOUA STATEMENT ABOUT LILL.
OBVIOUCOLID
HILLINTON   WERNO
FAVORITE.
HE COULDPTUIET.
E DOESN'T HAVE A TWITTER
UNF
ERSATION AND HE'S GOING PUG OUT
McAULIFFE IN VIRGINIA CONTINUINN
NE T
THE MORE HE KEEPT  MORE TRAPS
BENEFIOULD BE.
WORKS?HINK THE IDEA  TRYING
TO TIE GLEN GKIN, TH
L MI DONALD  THARSDO PEOPLK, IT
IIN. SOUTHERN MO
COMPLICATED.
VIRGINIA HAS BECOME NORTHERN AT.
OU START TSEE THIS
DISTANCE PUT IN THWO
DONALD TRUMP IS OFF THE E.WHEN
TRUM FND GLEN IN DOES NOT T AS .
TRUMS  THIS AND YOU REMIND
HIM AND SEE HIM EVERY DAY IT'S
GOING TO STICK MORE.
M N  WOULD
LOVE DONTRXT
AN IN
SENATOR CASSID TWAS,
A REPUBLICAN OF UISIANA, SAID
HEOUAN
'S AOULD NOTUP HIMBUT
NEW POLL I JUST SAW OUEASIIF A A
PERCENTAGEHA A FEW
MONTHS AGO OF BL
L, HA TY WITREPUBLICAN Y AND SO
.
HIMSELF WITE , ANRE THAVE IN A
FAMILIES FEEL PRETTY
IN THEPANDEMIC.
>> YOU HAVE DEMOCRATIC
GOVEEMOCRATIC
RIGHT NOW.
TERRFFE HA H
WOULD CONTINUESE
ENS TO ACTUAL ES OOHEN IT
RACE.
>>AK RAC, NEW YORK de BLASIO DR
NOT HE'S GOING TO RU
YO'STH ERR
TH SO
COY
NEW YORK VOTERS VIEW HIMFAFRABL.
CUOMO HAS BETT PL ER de BLASIOT
HE
T ABOUT DO YOUIO HAS ANY?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I WHAT'S
MO IS RIVALR
TWO POLITICIANS WHO HATE EACH
OTHER I DON'T KNOW WHO.
HE WANTS HIM -- PROBABLY TITE I.
SOANDREW CUOMO WASCE
RESIGN, SO NOW I'M GOING TO
IT.
>> IT'S NO PET,
>> POLL NUMBER'T HOLD HI
BACK FROM JUMPING INTO THE
HE RAN F